la vie riche et professeur à
l'université sorbonne nouvelle
spécialiste des relations
internationales coauteur du livre
l'europe et la chine à face à de
nouveaux enjeux une mondialisation
contrariée avec un julien vercueil aux
éditions lamarre temps bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france parlez nous un peu de la
situation des ouigours c'est un peuple
qu'on ne connaît pas beaucoup
à écouter ces taux peuvent s'ils
commencent à les connaître aussi les
habitent dans la plus grande province à
l'ouest de la chine
et comme vous savez ce sont ceux qui le
peuple d'origine turque historiquement
et qui est aujourd'hui en voie
d'assimilation perdre le pouvoir central
chinois et qui se traduit notamment par
locarno lourd de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans des camps de
rééducation avec comme le dira toute une
série de mesures concernant une sorte
d'assimilation forcée ou pas et qui va
en parallèle avec une politique de
peuplement disons de d1 dans la région
donc c'est un processus engagé déjà
depuis de nombreuses années et qui
explique pourquoi les pays occidentaux
démocratiques ce sujet autres cette
politique c'est une communauté musulmane
corps proches pékin justement à tata
communautaire c'est-à-dire de conserver
ses traits culturels au terme de
pratique religieuse le mode de vie avec
une très forte comme audi reproduction
de la population et cetera donc c'est
quelque chose qui échappe qui peut
échapper aux contrôles aux normes qui
sont apposés par par pékin donc la peur
c'est de voir que la croissance de cette
minorité votre dîner peu comment dire
échappé en quelque sorte au contrôle que
le power des sirbe m honneur à notre
autre de cette catégorie la population
chinoise
il existe des groupes radicaux sata
communauté atteinte à la sécurité
justement l'un des territoires chinois à
l'intérieur de la chine oui il ya eu des
mouvements récemment faceo voilà depuis
quelques années avec des attentats qui
avaient été perpétrés par exemple quand
on essaiera donc les mouvements
radicaliser et puis il y a dix ont un
support de cette population à
l'extérieur avec des comédiens de rigaud
qui de l'extérieur il y a des comment
dire des jo des leaders qui sont à
l'extérieur de la chine et qui animent
des noms pour comedia porter l'attention
sur ce qui se passe chez eux mais ce que
tu as fait le tout à fait normal à mon
avis c'est à dire qu'il n'ya que des
radicaux qui soit derrière il ya pour
dire d'interrogation globale à la fois
des membres de cette population derrière
les servir de la chine certains peuvent
être très radicaux d'autres des zoos des
comportements qu'on pourra qualifier de
citoyens normaux que ça alors on peut
s'étonner d'avoir justement les états
unis s'inquiétaient pour cette
communauté est ce qu'il y à là d un
terrain il n'y a pas tellement d'intérêt
américains c'est une question de
principe sur les droits de l'homme alors
on peut dire évidemment que les chinois
aujourd'hui si on tient compte de l'état
des relations entre la chine et les
états unis les états unis peuvent open
profité pour dix ont continué
mon triste les séparent du système
chinois ça c'est évident si vous voulez
il ya une approche qui est celle
classique de défense des droits de
l'homme et disons être similaire cei
départ et puis il ya le contexte des
relations sino américaines aujourd'hui
et je crois que l'accélération de la
contrainte sur les niveaux donne
l'occasion aux etats-unis 2 dont on sait
clous vis à vis de la chine il ya des
sanctions américaines prises à
l'encontre de certains dirigeants
chinois pékin qui annonce possiblement
des représailles
quel type de représailles on va écouter
les socios américaines se sont
formellement reconnaître
pourquoi parce que cette vidéo que les
apparatchiks
les jeux seront chargés d'opérer la
réflexion cette région ne sont pas des
milliardaires qui dispose de fonds d'un
porto placés dans les banques
américaines donc que c'est quelque chose
de purement formelle disons cible un peu
d d d acteurs en évitant d'ailleurs de
cibler les responsables politiques
ça touche pas le le premier défi
présomption est à l'origine de cette
politique donc on voit bien que c'est un
phénomène assez pour dire formelle et
qui dans la réalité on ne va pas
contraindre énormément les choses d'une
part d'autre part on voit pas comment
les chinois peuvent les jo chinois
peuvent cibler aussi nous aider quand on
voit l'état
si vous prenez par exemple l'état des
relations entre les correspondants des
journaux des chaînes de télévision entre
les etats-unis et la chine doit dire que
on peut pas tenir
on ne peut pas tarir pour dire on peut
pas venir tout le monde notre époque
chine de ce point de vue là le problème
quand même qui est important c'est que
d'un côté les pays occidentaux où se
il agite le boulonnais de l'homme et en
même temps ne font rien pour dit
souhaiter les schirm de leur pays
d'aller investir dans cette région bien
sûr elles sont contraintes vous prenez
le cas de volkswagen volkswagen était
obligé de construire une usine en
signant de nike à apple etc
les usines dans cette région et on a
montré une cycle des firmes de qui
produisent les vêtements avaient pouvez
bénéficier de ce travail des prisonniers
des pigeons qui sont dans les camps et
c'est donc le problème des pays
occidentaux se serait aussi de merci
merci à vous la verrez jamais recevait
professeur à l'université sorbonne
nouvelle